uh congrats on the movie i want to start
with that uh logan i just have to start
with you um are you prepared for like
the next year
to eight years uh being called podcast
wherever you go
i love it i mean the character's awesome
so i don't i don't know if i'll ever get
tired of it we'll see though i mean if
it goes for eight years maybe i might
get tired of it but
um i think i'll definitely like it at
first
yeah get get get ready um so uh for both
of you i i love learning about the
behind the scenes of the making of a
film or tv show what do you think people
would be surprised to learn about the
making of this ghostbusters movie
um i think that people would be really
surprised to know that a lot of
our sets and props and
cool
um puppets were actually practical so so
they
had huge like construction teams with
like forklifts and cranes and
and um just crazy equipment actually
building these sets and so when we like
step into these scenes in the movie we
are actually stepping into like a 50
foot or 40 foot tall set
so that's pretty cool um and like so
let's say um there's a lot of practical
affection here and you know since it's
an it's a newer you know burt in 2021 or
2020
no not 2019 we filmed that wow that was
a long time ago anyway when we filmed
that you know people are like oh man
there's gonna be a lot of cgi and stuff
but no we did a lot of practical and i
i'm really proud of them for actually
doing that and taking the time to to
work through it it was amazing it's
really cool to look at sometimes when i
speak to actors like a big group of
actors uh that made a movie like this uh
there's like a group text did you guys
like start a group text when you were
making it or do you have one and who is
the one who texts too much
well we did it we didn't have a group
chat
who two texted the most
maybe mckenna maybe mckenna yeah she's
really enthusiastic i love her
this is awesome
um i'm definitely curious which of your
friends and family members were the most
excited when you got cast who went like
above and beyond
i i have to say my dad my dad was like
yeah
at me every time i mean he's still
excited like we called him last night
because like we did the panel and he was
like you did so good
he was really excited so yeah my dad
really loves it yeah actually it was
probably my dad too i think for me my
dad i don't think he realized that
acting was like a real thing that i was
doing until i called him and i told him
and i that i got this part i called him
i told him and he was like
wow he was so excited his first his
literally first sentence was does this
mean i get to meet bill murray
this is so funny
that's the thing were you able to
actually because i would imagine listen
i i think the fact that bill murray and
the original ghostbusters are in this
movie is awesome did you end up like
basically saying to jason hey i really
want to bring
so and so to set when they're here do
you know what i mean or was he because i
know it's a closed set i'm just curious
how that works
yeah it was it was a closed set it was
it was kept pretty under wraps but it i
mean it was amazing just getting to meet
them at all
um so it was literally the coolest thing
ever
i agree
so switching to something else uh
there's always a challenge when you're
making a movie in terms of pulling off a
sequence what ended up being like the
really the toughest shot to pull off for
each of you
for me i would say
um there's a really cool moment at the
end i won't spoil it for anybody but i
get to do some stunts and
that that was difficult and challenging
and really cool for me because i had
never done anything like it before
and um just getting to be really
physical
um in that kind of final sequence um was
really challenging and also the most fun
part of shooting
well
i hope i can say this at the very end of
the movie
uh there's you know there's some parts
there and i think the most difficult
thing was there was a makeup thing that
i had to sit in my chair for like an
hour
and they were just doing my makeup on my
face and and hair and and i had to wear
the the jumpsuit and it was it was
very uncomfortable i'll just say that
but if you want to understand what i'm
saying here you'll have to watch the
movie um
so yeah that i think that part was the
hardest for me
and that don't i got to stop i'm going
to say seriously congrats to both of you
you both did great work in this have a
great day
thank you very much